The Joe Rogan Experience but I mean
again how does how do these systems
really work
um you know that so this is my kind of
conspiracy detection kit you know the
grander The Conspiracy Theory the less
likely it is to be true like say
Volkswagen cheating the emission
standards in uh Europe that you know
that's a very specific conspiracy theory
turned out to be true they really did do
that and for obvious reasons profit
motive right but but but so if you scale
up from that well they're trying to
control the entire European uh economy
or something like well no that's too big
that's just trying to make money they're
just trying to make money right so
um you know the the more people that
have to be involved the more elements
that have to come people are incompetent
people can't keep their mouth shut for
the most part for the most part yes now
yeah to be fair to to the other side
um you know if you read about the
development of the YouTube spy plane and
the ar-71 Blackbird you know this was
done in Burbank yeah near where you used
to live and that's right in the heart of
La how did they do this for all those
years and nobody knew about it right
well they were acting on the the
interests of the the government they
were trying to be Patriots they kept
their mouth shut because they were
trying to win a war against the the evil
others right so
um again like with the recent UAP
sightings
what I want my initial response is the
SR-71 Blackbird was before it was
Declassified they were commercial pilots
going oh my God there's something right
going 3000 miles an hour 50 000 feet
above me at 30 000 feet this is
impossible we don't have anything like
that well actually we did have something
like that yeah so I suspect that that's
what you think I think in a decade or
two we're going to find out oh we had
these incredible drones you could fly at
these speeds I I tend to lean towards
that as well sometimes I go back and
forth with it I had uh Ryan Graves on
recently I saw that it was a fascinating
conversation because the way he was
describing things with no visible means
of propulsion
um no technology that we currently know
is available could act in the way those
things were acting I wonder if that is
what it is if they have some sort of a
very Advanced drones and the fact that
they seem to be trans medium they seem
to be able to enter into the ocean and
then leave the ocean I wonder I wonder
if that's something that we have because
these things they're you know one of the
ones that he described is like a
translucent circle with a black sphere
inside of it and that when they updated
their radar systems in 2014 they started
seeing them all over the place on their
systems and that these people spotted
them visually and that they were
behaving in a way like at you know 130
mile an hour winds or completely
stationary I wonder if those are super
Advanced drones there are a lot of
another problem with these videos is
that they're very grainy uh blurry you
can't quite make out what's going on
like the one that it looks like it goes
in the ocean comes back out it's not
clear that it goes in the ocean because
it the the the Horizon and the ocean is
so blurry right so I'm a member of this
Galileo project at Harvard run by avilo
the head of the astronomy Department I
had Avion yep I know and uh you know
we're he's raising money to put cameras
high resolution cameras all over the
world right particularly in the places
where people like Graves say they I mean
when Graves told you I we saw these
things every day it's like every day
yeah there surely must be high
resolution photos but those things those
jets are not designed to take high
resolution video they're designed to
fight against enemy Jets right that's
what they're designed for they're
designed to recognize these enemy
combatants and engage with them in the
most effective way possible that's not
with high resolution digital video right
well that would be the
um that would be the solution we just
need better data right well I wonder if
they want better data now let's assume
the government but listening the federal
government imagine they are running top
secret programs using Advanced drones
and in technology that we're not
currently aware of right and that the
United States government has these they
wouldn't want people taking videos of
these things why would they
right but everyone has one of these in
their pocket yeah but why don't we have
digital video of something that's seven
miles away moving at you know right
right the speed of sound we're not going
to get digital video that's what we want
to do with the Galileo project and
according to them Christopher melon a
guy who you know did work for the
defense department he said there are Top
Secret videos and photographs that he's
seen or that he's aware of that are
pretty spectacular that they don't
understand right I've heard him say that
it's like okay then let's see him yeah
but why would they release that this is
this is the question is like if they
just like the Blackbird just like this
stealth bomber many of the other
projects that they have that were top
secret before they became public why
would they release all that information
probably wouldn't right yeah right I
wonder what that stuff is and the fact
that it happened so often in that very
specific area you know who knows another
thing I was thinking about with the eops
is in the history of Technology no
Nation gets very far ahead of any other
Nation right they either back engineer
to copy it or steal the secrets and so
on it's not likely we would have
anything that the Russians and Chinese
wouldn't be pretty close to having also
you know to think of just the
development of Jets or the development
of the nuclear bomb the nuclear bomb I
mean the Russians had you know so 1945
was Hiroshima and 1949 the Russians they
stole our secrets right so this idea
that you know these are super Advanced
uh drones that we have and the Russians
and Chinese don't have it's not likely
they would not know the technology that
we know the physics the aerodynamics and
and the engineering and all that because
they they read the same journals they do
the same research we do so what do you
think it is
well I well I think it's probably
multiple things I think some of them
might be drones that just really high
high-tech drones some of them are just
blurry videos that are I think the one
of the sphere inside the cube or the
Cuban size sphere is probably a balloon
a balloon yeah a balloon that stands
stationary at 130 mile an hour winds it
appears this stand station appears with
the most sophisticated tracking devices
these Military Jets have I know these
are anomalies yeah so we just need
better why would you think it's a
balloon well what else would it be okay
it might be uh you know it might be a
drone certainly probably not an alien
spacecraft and so on certainly probably
not why do you say that well because
well this kind of gets into the argument
of the seti program there's so many
there's so much empty space out there
the chances of them finding us are
pretty slim I so I simply I say we find
planets all the time yeah but we are not
right telescopes and satellites and all
sorts of you know things that we send
into space but we find planets all the
time that are in the Goldilocks zone and
we have a very relatively
unsophisticated in terms of like what
we'd expect from something that's
capable of Intergalactic travel
relatively simple technology in
comparison to what we would think if you
took what we have today and you in
increased our capabilities you know a
thousand years from now you could
imagine that it would be quite easy for
someone to at least send a drone from
another planet to visit Earth and
observe this is the Fermi Paradox yes
that you know of and where are they well
of course most scientists like him don't
think they're they're here so I
separated scientists Michio Kaku thinks
they're here uh he's been a little fuzzy
about that he's not totally committed to
that he's totally committed he was here
he was here and he talked about it on
the podcast he said for the longest time
he was a skeptic oh yeah that's right
okay he has kind of come down on that
side a little bit but why would you be
firm on that when you think about the
fact that there's hundreds of billions
of galaxies in the known universe let's
separate two questions are they are they
out there have they come here are they
out there almost certainly right I would
say you know 99.9 they're out there I
would agree with you 100 billion stars
in our galaxy 100 billion trillion
galaxies just do the numbers yeah no
matter how improbable it is you get from
bacteria to big brains and and
civilization it's going to happen right
but but have they come here okay so how
good is the evidence for that not very
it's pretty thin right how good
anecdotal it's human it's human
eyewitnesses it's blurry videos granny
photos
if they were here damn it where's the
you know pick up the the widget on the
dashboard and bring it back here but
just looking at what we know that these
fighter pilots have witnessed the data
that they've acquired when they're
looking at something like
Commander David fravor who when they
were off the coast of the with the the
Nimitz when they tracked that thing that
went from above 60 000 feet above sea
level to 50 feet above sea level in less
than a second what's that I don't know
yeah what is that something that they
have a visual they have visual contact
by multiple sources and they tracked it
and they have video of this thing moving
off at insane rates of speed what's that
yeah I don't know this is the problem
with anomalies no Theory explains
everything right but if there was any
evidence that pointed to something that
operated in a way that we can't
comprehend any of the known Technologies
being able to reproduce that's that's
one of them but no Technologies come out
of a vacuum like that they always build
on previous technology right but if
you're talking about something from
another planet well okay or something
from another another civilization that
we're not aware of that's on Earth maybe
that lives in the water we don't know we
don't know and when you're seeing these
things when you're talking about people
that are the the best fighter pilots
that we have available that are
operating with the most sophisticated
fighter jets with tracking systems that
are you know constantly being updated
and then when they update them they
start picking up these things like Ryan
Graves discussed on the podcast why
would you think that those are not
possibly something from somewhere else
it depends on how you want to like
oppose the the problem so here's how I
think about it so I take Leslie Keane's
um a book on UFOs and you know pilots in
generals go on the record and so on in
that book she says 90 to 95 of all
sightings have perfectly normal
explanation I would probably agree
that's true so the question is what do
we do with that other five percent of
anomalies okay no Theory explains
everything there's always going to be
anomalies in every scientific theory
what do you have what do you do with it
nothing you assign it to a graduate
student figure it out or you know that's
future research you know rather than
going to you know a grand theory of
visitation by aliens or the Russians or
Chinese have these super Advanced
Technologies that we don't have or we
have them and they don't have I mean
again if if we had this technology
surely the Russians have something
pretty close to that there's nothing in
uh from the videos in Ukraine of any
Russian drones that act anything like
these uaps surely they would use this
technology if they had it well we're
assuming that those uaps are military
in nature and not something that they
use to observe things could be I mean
why would we assume that these things if
they're capable of behaving in this way
and they're just some sort of a device
that can travel at in same rates of
speed why would we assume that those
things can launch missiles or act in a
military capacity right and you know
there are UAP sightings over Ukraine
yeah but okay so Avi did a nice paper on
that showing that these were
artillery shells and not what they the
other people said they thought they
thought it was that it was like a drone
or a plane or something weird like that
he showed that if if it was what they
thought it was it would have had a much
bigger impact going through the
atmosphere at that speed and burning up
but it didn't so these are artillery
shells anyway he did a nice paper on
that interesting so but what about these
things that supposedly move far faster
than the speed of sound without the
sonic boom
yeah how is that possible how is that
possible that's right it's not that's
that's where it gets weird that's where
it gets weird right but that's where it
is it ours is it really moving at that
speed or is it a misperception of the
video a miscalculation people make
scientists make miscalculations of these
sorts of things all the time yeah that
was one of the things that was posed to
David fravor and he said they have
multiple sources of of data there it's
not just like one system that's
monitoring these things it's multiple
systems yeah
and I follow these guys I agree they are
incredibly credible right and they have
good arguments what do you do with the
anomaly I think you are an
anti-conspiracy theorist that's what I
think no I'm a skeptic I know you are
I'm just you literally are I'm just an
editor what's your position in skeptic
magazines I'm the editor-in-chief yeah
publisher yeah big magazine yeah you're
literally a scout yeah that is my day
job yeah but it isn't that I don't
believe things uh I mean I believe the
theory of evolution I think the Big Bang
Theory happened when people like uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson and and my my quantum
physics friends tell me quantum physics
is true this is how we know it to me
it's weird spooky I don't really
understand it but okay you know there we
have tons of evidence